hello everyone and welcome to round two
of this year's Champion Chester finals
it is Fabiano Carana versus ala fua this
is the first game of their match and
going into round two both of them come
off with a victory Fabiano defeated
Maxim velag grav in round one he won the
first game then he lost the second one
and he defeated him in the tie breaks
whereas alza was able to take down Notre
Abdus satov in Rapid without going into
Armageddon but this one I'm sure you
guys would agree is the uh absolute best
game played yesterday
so we're going to focus on this one
let's check it out Fabby has the white
pieces and he opens with E4 I included
the clock times for this one as it is
relevant so 15 minutes per player uh
let's check it out we have Pawn to E5
Knight F3 Knight to C6 and Bishop to C4
the Italian game is on the board Bishop
to C5 the Joo piano Sorry I immediately
think that black always plays this
Knight to F6 the two knights defense and
now Pawn to D3 uh we have Bishop to C5
and now we have castles transposing in
into the Joo piano we have Pawn to D6
and C3 uh castles and now Pawn to H3 so
there are many many games in the
database this is the top Main Line
played by both of them A6 we have A4
stopping B5 Bishop to A7 so you don't
have any temp on the bishop later on and
Rook to E1 we have Pawn to H6 both
players just playing useful moves it's
in pretty much every jaop piano you will
have the H pawns and a pawns pushed up
the board Knight B to D2 going for the
standard maneuver of the Knight then to
F5 or H5 Rook to E8 and now Pawn to B4
grabbing more space on the queen side we
have Bishop to E6 and now you trade
Bishop captures Rook captures and Bishop
to B2 so again many many games in the
database we have Knight to H5 preparing
to put the to put the Knight on F4 and
the bishop here is an absolute Beast we
have Knight to F1 and now there is a
game where Rook to G6 was played right
away but here we have Knight to the E7
and it is now as of move 14 that we have
a completely new game so let's see how
uh Fabby deals with this idea of course
the Knight is coming to G6 and then all
depending on what he plays F4 or H4
probably F4 uh we have Pawn to C4 he
grabs more space in the center gains
full control over the D5 square is ready
to continue advancing on the queen side
but he does weaken the D4 square a
little bit which means it will be harder
to execute D4 and this bishop becomes um
perhaps an even stronger piece we have
Knight to G6 and now Pawn to G3 and not
allowing the Knight to land on F4 or H4
but alza doesn't care he just plays
Knight G to F4 and he offers a piece
here now if uh this was handled by
someone who is afraid to calculate maybe
something like king T H2 was played but
Fab is well known for his execution of
engine moves so he just captures the
Knight says all right come at me G
captures on F4 and now Rook to G6 check
King to H2 and Knight captures on F4 so
okay he's down a piece but he does have
a very uh unpleasant pressure here Rook
to G2 will be a very nasty threat of
course if the queen comes to D7 then the
H3 Pawn might be in trouble uh but Fabby
is confident that he will be able to
defend this he plays Knight to E3 this
stops Rook to G2 and after Queen to D7
how do you defend this how do you defend
Queen captures on H3 well interestingly
best way to do it is Knight to F5 uh
Fabby did not go for this because it
involves giving up the F2 Pawn but you
should give it up and after Rook F1 and
Bishop to G3 check uh you don't take of
course and allow Queen captures on H3
you just move the king back and now if
Knight captures on H3 you're just going
to play Queen to C2 and okay you're up a
piece you're going to put the Rook on G1
uh and um defend well uh however after
Queen to D7 uh Fabby decided to defend
with Knight to G1 this does defend the
H3 Pawn but what's the only thing
stopping ala from capturing on H3 it's
of course the Knight on G1 so he just
captures it Rook captures on G1 King
captures if you capture with the Rook of
course it's just Checkmate so you have
to capture with the King and now Queen
captures on H3 so the Knight is uh still
guarding against Checkmate uh so you
have to prevent Bishop captures on E3 at
all cost so uh here uh we have Pawn to
C5 and now uh if you if you're not
careful uh you will uh lose the game
here but if you're careful you will win
the game here so there is only one
winning move for alza here and all the
other moves are winning for Fabby so
what do you play here feel free to pause
the video and figure out how to go about
this position while I give you a couple
of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
realizing White's only move in this
position that is Queen to G4 and
congratulations if you figure out a way
how to stop that and that is Pawn to H5
and that is why uh in the previous
position where Fabby played Pawn to C5
Queen to G4 was the way to go it still
gives ala a beautiful position but maybe
just maybe it will be possible to defend
point is that after Bishop captures on
E3 uh you will capture on H3 okay Knight
captures but it happens with check and
after the king moves King to G2 Knight
to F4 check King F3 and now you can even
play Bishop captures on F2 and after
King captures Knight captures here with
a fork uh King F3 you're going to captur
The Rook here and okay fa will be up a b
but alza will have three extra pawns and
it will be alza who will be pushing for
the win here probably Fabby can defend
with the extra piece however after C5 uh
such a thing is no longer possible
possible H5 now there's no Queen to G4
and you don't really have a move here
now The Rook is coming into the game and
also the pawn is uh continuing uh its
March down the board so Rook E2 Fabby
will try to trade off Queens but now
Rook to E8 we have Queen to F1 now
Knight captures on E2 with check Queen
captures and Rook to E6 preparing this
nasty Rook to G6 check so Knight to G2
we have Rook to G6 and now Queen to F1
the only way to defend against checkmate
but now H4 preparing to move the queen
and continue advancing this Pawn down
the board we have Rook to C1 uh but uh
it uh doesn't do all that much ala even
uh continues playing positional chess
here with with Pon A5 you can see the
situation on the clock 27 minutes
seconds for Fabby 28 seconds for alza so
it's not easy but they of course will
fight we have Bishop C3 and now just
Queen to G4 preparing Pawn to H3 so Fabi
unpins King to H2 but still Pawn to H
three we have Knight to E3 and now Queen
to F4 with check King to H1 and now
Queen to F3 check they repeat once
because you also have to you know win a
few seconds on the clock before you uh
deliver the final execution now D
captures on C5 we have B captures on C5
and queen to F3 check King H2 and now
Bishop captures on C5 and now of course
it all comes back to this Knight on E3
Bishop captures will eliminate the
defender and Rook G2 will decide the
game so Faby played Queen to H1 hoping
to get a queen trade in but ala just
played Queen captures on F2 check and it
was in this position on move 37 that
Fabiano corana resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
you either give up the queen or you Capt
on H3 then Queen to G3 is Checkmate or
you block with the Knight also doesn't
help you Queen to G3 will still be
Checkmate so yeah Fab resigned Queen
captures on F2 was played and alza wins
a very nice first game however Fabby
retaliated in the second game with the
black pieces they uh went into armag
and the Armageddon game ended in a draw
it was also a very tricky one Fabby was
winning pretty much throughout the
entire game but in the end alare was
able to save the the draw however a draw
as Fabby had the black pieces means that
he wins the the armagon so Fabby wins
both of his matches against MBL and
against ala in Armageddon uh so very
nice game hope you guys enjoyed it if
you have any others from this event
always use hash suggestion because
that's how I filter out your suggestions
I would like to thank David Gaspar and
chaer Albert vardell Nathan I love you
Dad and Milos kovich for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day